here's what would happen if a spoonful
of neutron star appeared on Earth
if you tried to scoop up some of the sun
with a teaspoon you'd get about two
kilograms of it now the same spoonful of
a neutron star would weigh anywhere from
one to six billion tons yeah you
wouldn't be able to lift that spoon
also because the gravity of a neutron
star is so intense it fuses protons and
electrons together only neutrons are
left in that Stellar core and when they
aren't buried deep down inside a star
neutrons don't last too long after 10
minutes your spoonful of neutron star
would break down into protons and
neutrons and release as much energy as
the sun produces in two or three seconds
good thing you didn't have enough time
to bring that stuff back to Earth
because it would have ended all life so
leave neutron stars where they belong
far far away from us because